et maintenant avec le temps avec
tout s'en va voici jean d'ormesson
j'entends me sens
il m'en voulez pas si vous abattre appel
à nous non j'en ai désolé il peut pas
m'embrasser sur la bouche parce qu'il
est académicien
enfin je peux vous remplacer alors j'ai
reçu un mail après votre dernier passage
dans l'émission un mail de arnaud
salomon qui a 25 ans et qui habite à
lille et qui dit juste pour dire qu'en
voyant jean d'ormesson
ça donne vraiment envie de devenir
académicien ça je sais sincèrement
voilà bien lui qui voulait appeler adieu
donc voilà en fait je les hits et entre
adieu les carottes sont cuites il va
faire est dans le sac kenya les 40 en
famille ou entre le voilà le travail
c'est pas mal et finalement donc ça
s'appelle c'était bien et c'est chez
gallimard mesdames messieurs
e
voilà c'était bien alors c'est pas un
roman c'est pas des mémoires c'est pas
un essai c'est quoi un truc à faire un
truc itamar à vous auriez dû le marquer
à la place et reste un truc on sait pas
ce que c'est bon c'est pas les mémoires
non mais on ne fait pas un effet pas ce
qu'on me dit de quoi parlez vous j'avais
très peur qu'on me disait de quoi parlez
vous vraiment c'est très compliqué c'est
elle c'est une espèce de des tas d uvre
est voilà comment commence avant voilà
comment sa valeur pendant que j'explique
comment ça va j'explique aussi aux
lecteurs comment lui va voilà à peu près
alors le pitch finalement sylvie le
pitch à l'académie ce mot h compte sur
vous pour que le mot pitt se rendre dans
le duc sera la langue française
alors je n'ai pas encore fait entre à
l'académie j'ai fait entrer chez
gallimard et je leur ai dit je vais vous
expliquer le pic le pic personne que
gallimard savez ce que vous voulez mieux
le faire alors j'ai dit mais comment
vous n'écoutez par dix ans mais enfin
et à l'intention de ceux qui font les
études je leur ai même dit par exemple
quel est le pitch de faire la fête c'est
une dame est amoureuse de son beau fils
malheureusement le beau fils est victime
d'un accident la circulation voilà voilà
le pitch précède adéquat le pitch de la
recherche
le pitch l'ua cherche c'est un petit
garçon attendait et de sa mère de
l'asseoir dans la nuit et comme on ne
vient pas suffisamment à son gré il va
dans les bals pour se consoler voilà
voilà le pitch la recherche alors le
pizzo votre bouquin 10 ans et ma vie
bilan globalement très positif est ce
que je peux apporter un bémol
oui ce qui est positif c'est pas ma vie
c'est la vie c'est la vie de ma vie elle
aurait pu être mieux
je serai ému et je serai gide je serai
aragon je serai extrêmement satisfaits
n'étant pas bons les tempes à
châteaubriant n'étant pas gide
je suis un peu mélancolique mais ce qui
est bien c'est la vie c'est la vie c'est
la vie
en tous les cas ça donne vous l'avez
c'était bien alors en tous les cas vous
n'avez jamais eu besoin de psy voir non
vous avez survécu à la psychanalyse au
nouveau roman vous avez survécu à
jean-paul ça à ça c'est pas mal quand
même non bah oui il y en a qui ont
laissé des plumes
alors il ya une autre façon de pitch est
votre livre j'en sais il ya deux grandes
interrogations dans la vie l'une au
début c'est que faire et l'autre c'est à
la fin qu'ai-je fait c'est une façon de
le raconter aussi
alors écoutez je vois qui est ici il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont 20 ans et si je
vous dois quelque chose thierry et je
dois beaucoup
c'est que probablement vous m'avez
fournit des lecteurs plus jeune que ce
que j'avais
quand j'écrivais au plaisir de dieu
j'avais sûrement des lecteurs que j'aime
beaucoup mais qui était sûrement
beaucoup plus âgés et peut-être que les
gens fument
maintenant sont un peu plus jeunes grâce
en partie au clair c'est vrai dans ce
qu'il faut lire sans faire de fausse
modestie
c'est vrai que cette émission est
beaucoup regardé par les jeunes et que
quel bon délit est alors temps jamais
maintenant vous savez eh bien je
trouvais ça très dur vraiment je
trouvais ça très dur et pourtant j'avais
les avantages énormes à 20 ans j'étais
fonctionnaire
j'étais en train l'école normale j'étais
payé ma carrière était engagé bon en
plus quand j'avais 20 ans je crois que
le taux de chômage était de 0,4 pour
cent c'est à dire que ce qu'on voulait
faire on trouve et où il ya métier vous
trouviez et bien malgré ça j'ai trouvé
ça très dû à la voix m il y avait une
phrase célèbre de nos agents vous
connaissez je me permettrai à personne d
dire que 20 ans et le plus bel âge la
vie eh bien c'était vrai montant alors
je vous jure que je ne cherche pas à
faire de la démagogie
ouais mais je trouve que les gens qui
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui ont vraiment
beaucoup de courage parce qu'ils sont
très gais semblait très est très très
confiants et moi je trouve ça épatant
alors votre précédent livre jean
s'appelait voyez comment danse et ça
commençait déjà autour du cercueil d'un
ami à c'est déjà un peu vous commentez
d'une certaine façon vous savez c'est
vrai et vous savez quelque fois on me
dit alors qu'est ce que tu penses de ton
livre et je dis je ne sais pas je n'ai
encore vu personne et c'est les gens qui
lisent les livres qui m'apprennent et
qui tout à coup c'est vrai ce livre ci
tourne quand même beaucoup au tournoi de
l'année l'oréal annonce d'un départ
l'annnonce de ma mort est prématurée oui
mais enfin bon moi je suis et moi je
suis au fait ça pour qu'on vous il reste
avec nous regardez moi ces vols pogne
ses vols peuvent enfin le lift
précédents s'étaient déjà l'enterrement
et je sais pas peut-être que
quelques-uns d'entre vous se souviennent
d'un livre qui s'appelait la loisne le
maire
et je mourrai à la première page alors
évidemment c'est un problème qui m'a un
peu fait pour conjurer le sort je suis
sur moi c'est peut-être aussi certaines
vous savez on traite ange apparaît
beaucoup comme une espèce de champion un
peu benêt du bonheur crétins qui trouve
que tout va bien
il ya aussi sûrement une grande
mélancolie dont et dans mes livres
depuis le début mai mais l'ont connu à
ses gains jeudi à tous les gens qui sont
ici profiter de jean d'ormesson parce
qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup des comme ça
moi j'en profite au maximum si je
pouvais l'avoir planta en effet la barre
d'abord mairie je voudrais ajouter que
profiter de moi
vous l'avez pas pour si longtemps et
ensuite étiré jouez vous demandez est ce
que je pourrais avoir ici un rôle
serviette
oui mes pantoufles mais attendez parce
que quand j'arrive là évidemment j'ai
l'impression de mieux chez moi je vais
écouter pendant cache non que vous
voulez je voulais remplacer baffie vous
pouvez bien alors le contenu du bouquin
alors il ya cette phrase où vous dites
la vie c'est les livres les femmes et
les bains de mer et gaston gallimard lui
disait le danemark les femmes et alors
c'est quand même un jour il répond c'est
pas tant ouais et l'angoissé battant les
balmer bon vous voyez ce que c'est
sérieux pas seulement les mâles mais bon
les courses en voiture
l'italie
les îles grecques les voyages à voilà je
suis oiseau non voilà bon et puis les
femmes
alors ça c'est bien parce que on m'a
souvent dit à la télévision pas qu'une
aile et bien pas que tu n'aimes sur les
femmes
on n'en parle pas pour le moment il n'y
en a pas alors aînés livre alors on peut
en parler vous parle évidemment des
thèmes qui sont des thèmes ans mais
sonia come on come on dira bientôt le
privilège de la naissance le sens de
l'histoire vous parler du big bang
c'est très très riche si les thèmes
souvent abordés mais cette fois c'est
vrai qu'il ya une petite mélancolie ya
quelque chose d'un petit peu comme ça
quoi fêlure dans le cristal le thème de
la naissance j'ai pensé que au fond bon
j'ai été élevé ou est-ce que j'ai été
élevé
j'ai été levée dans un château bah oui
eh ben c'est mon trotskisme ya les gens
qui ont un passé trente ce qu'ils m'ont
très bien pourquoi pas les emmerder avec
ça éternellement
et ben moi non plus on va pas m'emmerder
entendu j'ai été élevé dans un château
est tout à fait du trotskisme y en reste
quelque chose du château il en reste
quelque chose aussi
mais on essaie d'oublier tout ça voilà
dans le bilan ou fait finalement de la
vie d'une certaine façon j'en sais
comment s'est guère plus sans parfum
qu'on arrive en quoi un nom alors si
c'était à refaire
si c'était à refaire je ne leur ferai
pas un non franchement j'ai trouvé ça
épatant j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé la
vie et si un bon génie ou un mauvais
génie disait voilà tu peux recommencer
je comprends comment serait évidemment
c'est bon comme ça
et évidemment amener la messe est dite
quoi la même si ça aurait été possible
mais c'est vite la messe est dite
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez si votre
vie était à refaire imaginons vous
acceptiez de la refaire que changeriez
quoi au foyer les mêmes les mêmes folies
des mêmes terrains au chant ouais je
tâche à peut-être de rencontrer un peu
plus tôt rassemblée survivre à votre
mort parce que vous allez rester dans la
postérité non la postérité
oui j'y croyais alors vous savez j'y
crois plus aux abords je pense que la
postérité il fasse est une idée de
l'avenir
eh bien je crois que cette idée de
l'avenir appartient au passé
vous savez pourquoi un peu à cause de
voix un peu à cause de la télévision la
télévision est une formidable machine à
éclairer mais la télévision est aussi
une machine à billets quand on ne passe
plus à la télévision les autres passent
et tout ça fait que on est balayé et
c'est très difficile je crois que ceux
d'hier
peut on restera dans la postérité avec
toute cette masse d'information du mage
d'événements qui roule sur le monde
c'était facile autant de flaubert ou
jeanne briand ne fera auprès des
émissions romain sur arte
moi je vous ferai les émissions hommage
vous promets la tête du mal on dira
qu'ils cessent dallas voilà vous êtes
très fort si vous avez ça arrive à faire
ce bouquin là sans parler de vous en
fait oui alors vous savez j'ai déjà là
il ya une différence avec les hommes
politiques c'est que eux disent toujours
nous sommes transparents oui moi je ne
suis pas français pas du tout non pas
lui mais à une époque où votre ami jean
marie rouart raconte ses coucheries à
montparnasse g7 et rieder
oui alors ça vous a pas donné un petit
peu l'idée vous d'aller un peu plus loin
dans les confidences alors roy dit tout
moi je n'ai pas grand chose non mais
d'ailleurs quand on veut lui les eric
quand on relit les articles ont été
écrits sur vous on s'aperçoit vous êtes
toujours méfier terriblement des
journalistes parce que vous laissait
rien paraître
vous devez vous méfier des biographes
parce qu'une fois que vous serez plus là
les mecs ils vont fouiller dans vos
papiers puissent avoir des roms ah ouais
l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir une
biographie mois et qu'on cherche dans ma
vie ça mais pouvant gma ne compte
chèques patronne mois prévient même même
si vous vous détruisez toutes les
lettres par exemple de femme c'est une
supposition que vous avez reçus pour
demander à ces femmes qui vous en avez
écrit déconstruire ont voulu tourner
rond lui tout en volutes ouvelle avons
fait un hommage
arte et c'est tout riendeau
d'accord alors bye des choses qu'on sait
pas mais par exemple si je suis très
curieux gens est ce que par exemple sur
l'asthme est ce que vous avez déjà fait
l'amour en costume d'académicien par
exemple non non jamais elles seront fort
même mais même j'aurais pu par exemple
le faire sans salle d'accueil missia
mais un bicorne tu leur nom
est-ce que vous avez déjà pratiqué des
jeux érotiques avec l'épée jean ah ah ah
non je fais de bon secours
on va vous expliquer sans arrêt que vous
êtes au bout du chemin gens nous on veut
pas le croire bien entendu on pense que
ce livre n'est destiné qu'à vous faire
aimer encore plus si c'est possible
et puis qui aura après alors encore
plein d'autres 1 c'était bien c'était
vraiment bien c'était vraiment super
bien mais quand même pour conjurer le
sort on va passer à votre oraison
funèbre est patent voici dieudonné